I told you that there were other threats
to Trump and I have a theory and I know
you're going to laugh at me so I if
you're driving I want you to pull over I
don't want to be responsible for any car
crashes I think there was a dark horse
candidate
what's got into them the secret Dark
Horse candidate that nobody's talking
about
Chris Christie I mean you're laughing
Michael there's no way we're going to
see a chrysosons I think we might be on
the cusp of a chrysosons hear me out
Chris Christie was the governor of New
Jersey very successful two-term governor
in New Jersey he was talked about as a
potential presidential candidate far
back as 2012 being a Northeastern
Governor is more liberal Centrist
moderate whatever you want to say than a
lot of people in The Party The
Establishment loves that but Chris
Christie being from New Jersey is
extremely obnoxious
it's pretty funny and he's got a kind of
gruff tough sense of humor which is
something that appeals to the base it
appeals to me it appeals to a lot of
people